hello everybody today it's a big day for
the markets we have CPI data coming out
a half 12 UTC time
and you can see that the market has been
holding in this Zone I think I mentioned
this in yesterday's video that it's
likely that the market was going to hold
until inflation numbers come out because
you know these numbers these results can
move the market we're in a market driven
by data so you know the investors and
institutions they're going to be waiting
first
to see what these numbers are and then
they're gonna react to them and today's
inflation data is very important also
considering that non-farm payrolls last
week or the labor market this is still
quite hot and that's something that the
FED is not going to like so if we see
today worse inflation numbers than they
expect
watch out because maybe we don't have a
pause straight away although I think
we're gonna see a post the rest of the
market thinks well when I see a post but
of course we want to see what the data
says they're expecting five percent
that's basically well five percent
inflation does the same as as the
previous result in in March so if we see
something like 5.2 percent or higher the
Market's going to dump and the volar
index is gonna go up all right now if we
see something that is four to eight
percent or lower the markets are going
to pump and that could be the Catalyst
for this production to play out because
yes this prediction is still invalidated
you can see that we came all the way to
the week
fill the week and now we're going
sideways right now if we check the fifth
EMA we can see that we are right below
it okay this is a resistance but of
course if you get very good
results today then the market pumps you
could see maybe something like this okay
playing over the next days you could see
a push a retrace to test the 50 EMA as
support and then you can say
contribution to the website at least to
these two liquidity pools that go all
the way to 28 750
and 28 570.
okay so that's what I'm keeping an eye
on let's see what the inflation numbers
are we have to plan both the scenarios
are the inflation data is going to be is
it going to be good or bad if it's good
then yes the 50ma you have to clear this
Zone hopefully come back to it and test
your support that's where you would be
open in Longs all right and then you can
take profits along the way in these two
liquidity pools and if there is enough
momentum why not we can go all the way
here
this liquidity pool in the daily time
frame so you can see more clearly here
all right so that's the bullish scenario
if we have good CPI numbers now
what can happen if we get bad inflation
numbers
now if we see really about inflation
date and with that I mean at least a
difference of 0.2 percent with the
forecast would expect it that's going to
make the dollar Index pump okay it's
gonna go up why because if we get worse
inflation than expected and you put that
together with the bad non-farm payrolls
data that we saw on Friday then the
expectations for a rate pause are going
to slow down and remember that the
dollar Index goes up
with every hike on the interest rates so
that's why I think that if we see bad
inflation numbers the dollar is going to
go up and remember that Bitcoin trades
against the dollar
okay so Bitcoin just is gonna go down
also there is some kind of client of
correlation between Bitcoin and SMP and
SMP should go down so everything would
align together to say Bitcoin going
lower
well if you check the chart let me
remove all of this okay so we don't get
confused if we look at the chart now
this is the data time frame we are below
the 50ma we still haven't tested as
resistance you can see that these two
weeks has enriched the 50ma so still
really we haven't tested our resistance
so there is some hope that we see a
recover okay that still can happen now
if we start to see that's the 50ma and
we start to see something like this
testing resistance and of course they
want to see price going lower okay now
if we see very bad inflation data
we will see price going to this Zone
over here okay around 26 500 that's kind
of like the last support before going to
25k because 25k is a very interesting
Zone
you can see here
the price reached 25 250 we saw a
sell-off then price went back up again
and there was another sell-off in this
exactly the same place the question is
have we tested this on last support yet
no not really and it's quite important
zone so that's what I mean if we start
to see Bitcoin going down from here
we're gonna test twenty six thousand
five hundred we're gonna go now to
Hardware capital in a moment to see all
the liquidations and if we lose 26 500
then the next Target is going to be 25
250.
what in high block Capital with
liquidation heat pumps let's go to the
seven days time frame I'm gonna go
through all of them okay you can see
that in the saving this time frame we
came and hit all these liquidations now
we are consolidating right below them
and well you can see that really in the
same in this time frame all the
liquidity
is really in the thirty thousand Zone
okay and this is pretty much the the
liquidity pool that we saw in the daily
time frame now today let's go to the
monthly time frame
the monthly time frame I think this
chart is a lot more interesting
because you can see liquidity
about sites okay you can see it all the
way to 30 3001 300 and higher to 31 300.
um this is basically the liquidity put
in the daily time frame and this is
above the previous highs because I think
we made a higher 31 100 if I'm not wrong
or Thirty One Thousand so these
liquidations are right above the
previous size because there is always
liquidity above previous Highs are below
previous lows
and up to the downset and this is
getting interesting because to be honest
if you look at the chart what's closer
thirty thousand or twenty six thousand
of course 26 000 is closer and there is
a lot of liquidations at twenty six
thousand four hundred
so you know this can't give us
Confluence to see that if price goes
lower today because the inflation data
is bad
then twenty six thousand four hundred is
going to be the next one okay let's go
to the three months time frame
of course you know in the opposite way
if we get very good inflation data today
we're gonna go higher okay let me check
this
okay I see a lot of liquidity here
you can see that this zone is getting
brighter and bright and that's 32 31 200
right above the previous High
and to the downside I still see 22 000
this could be in my opinion the next
level after 25k so if we this is an
essential okay if we lose 25k if we go
level to 25k and we lose 25k then 22 000
should be the next Zone and then if you
get to the six months time frame this is
my favorite time frame I've said this
many times six month time frames if you
notice the chart look at the chart
it has been nailing every single move
you see there is liquidity here price
goes there now we're in this Zone
um there is something to be some
liquidations here price goes there at
the second time we see that it has
formed some nucleations here price goes
down again
to this Zone press continue sitting all
these liquidations on the way
and then we are here doing some
consolidation and we see this yellow bar
price goes there
and if you look at the chart now the
next Zone that has the most liquidations
is 22 500 so this is concerning in my
opinion because for what I've seen this
in this chart you know playing out it
plays out pretty well the six months
time frame and it's telling me that 22
500 is the Zone in the chart
with the highest interest of regarding
liquidation so this is why I can't
discardedia
down again I mean I'm not saying fifteen
thousand or sixteen thousand but
22 why not you know the cards are there
on the table anyway guys I'm gonna say
what I always tell you it's not
Financial advice but it's my personal
recommendation for Jewel
and is to not be Overexposed to the news
announcements because what are you gonna
do tell me are you gonna open a long or
assured now
is going to say
because the market is going to react
Based on data okay and
that would be gambling to me so that's
what I always wait at least 30 minutes
after the news has come out the results
and then yes we can trade imbalances we
can again
if we go up then this is probably gonna
leave a liquidity pool behind and we
have the conference of the 1 hour 50ma
so then we could place our long here
okay and then price can go higher to
maybe this liquidity pool again it's not
Financial advice with just some ideas
what tell me what is it better to buy
now if to Long round or too long here
a confirmation of course a confirmation
now if the results are bad and we go
down okay let's see how long it goes
because maybe you know it goes all the
way down a straight away to 26 500 then
you can see some kind of sideways
here to the downside but price is not
breaking below this Zone do not remember
this was or support back in back in
March
and then if you see in this key soon we
actually down so the price is not going
lower then you could expect some kind of
reversal to fill these imbalances here
all right so that's how I would suggest
you guys to trade news announcements
right anyway I hope that that was clear
and uh this video is helpful I'm sorry
that because we're very close to the to
the data it's gonna be in 45 minutes so
I'm gonna pause the video right now so
you guys can watch it thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you soon